اهلا بكم مشاهدي العربيه ونكمل هذه
التغطيه لاخبار السودان ونبدا بالعناوين
تجدد دال الشبكات العنيفه وذوي القذائف
وسطوم ومنطقه بحري ومحيط القصر الرئاسي
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
يحدد الاطراف السودانيه المتصارعه
بالعقوبات اذا لم تتوقف للقتال
الامم المتحده تعلن حاجتها لنحو نصف مليار
دولار لمساعده اكثر من 800 الف سوداني
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
يدعو لانشاء محكمه خاصه لمحاكمه روسيا
وموسكو تقصف اوديسا بالمسيرات الانتحاريه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تدور معارك طاحنه منذ
الفجر بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وذوي
الانفجارات والاشتباكات العنيفه سمع وسط
الخرطوم ومنتقد بحري في جوله شبيهه
بالايام الاولى لتفجر الصراع المسلح في
الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي الجيش
السوداني قال ان قوات الدعم السريع حاولت
الهجوم على منطقه بحر العسكريه في المقابل
ادانا الدعم السريع من سماهم قيادات الجيش
الانقلابيه بعد هجوم تعرضت له قواته في
عده مواقع وفي اول تعليق رسمي للحكومه
الاثيوبيه بخصوص الوسطات الدوليه لانهاء
الصراع في السودان قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الاثيوبيه ان بلاده تدعم جهود
وساطه الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
ومنظمه ايجاد وان الجهود الاحاديه الاخرى
ستؤذن الوضع في السودان
[موسيقى]
الوضع الحالي في السودان ستكون له تاثيرات
سلبيه علينا نتابع الوضع السوداني بقلق
بالغ ونؤكد تاييدنا دور الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه ايجاد في
الوساطه بين اطراف الصراع السوداني ونؤمن
بان الحوار هو الحل الوحيد للازمه
مشاهدينا الان على ما يبدو هناك حديث
للرئيس الامريكي بايدن حول موضوع السودان
يقول فيها بانه سيعاقبون كل من يستهدف
المدنيين في السودان ويعرقل الانتقال
السلمي للسلطه وايضا عن بايدن سنعاقب كل
الافراد المسؤولين عن تهديد واستقرار
السودان وهو طبعا ملتزم بدعم تطلعات الشعب
السوداني ايضا عن بايدن الشعب السوداني
متمسك بالديمقراطيه ويرفض الصراع على
السلطه وهو على استعداد لتلبيه المطالب
الانسانيه في السودان عندما تسمح الظروف
بايظ يقول ايضا بان النزاع في السودان يجب
ان ينتهي فورا اذا كانت هذه اخر تصريحات
الرئيس الامريكي بايدن بمواصله الجهود
الامريكيه لاحلال السلام واجراء مفاوضات
بين الاطراف السودانيه بالعوده للاخبار مع
استمرار المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع منذ الصباح والتي وصفت بالاعنف منذ
بدء الصراع افاد مراسل العربيه بان الجيش
سيطر على منطقه كوبر وسلاح الاشاره في
الخرطوم فيما تقوم قوات الجيش بتمشيط
منطقه كوبر بعد السيطره عليها هذا واظهرت
الصور استهدافا جويا لتمركزات الدعم
السريع في محيط القصر الجمهوري والقياده
العامه بالخرطوم في الاثناء لا تزال
الاوضاع الانسانيه والطبيه في تفاقم مستمر
فبينما اعلنت وزاره الصحه ان 70% من
المستشفيات بدات خارج الخدمه لجا سودانيون
للفرار من الاقتتال الدائر والصخ مخاوف من
ارتفاع موجه النزوح لارقام قياسيه
[موسيقى]
نشر لجيش السوداني مقطعا مصورا للمركبات
ولاسلحه تابعه للدعم السريع بعد اشتباكات
اخيره في محيط سلاح الاشاره في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم في المتابع
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
ولم تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخرق
الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي اخرها
اتهم بيان الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن
قصف عشوائي على عدد من مواقع تمركز قواتها
وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه الجديده
التي بدا سرايانها اليوم بيان الدعم
السريع اكد ان القصف الذي شنه الجيش
بالمدافع والطائرات يشكل تجاوزا للاعراف
والقوانين الدوليه في المقابل اكد الجيش
ان قوات الدعم السارقه حاولت الهجوم على
قياده منطقه بحر العسكريه واضاف الجيش
السوداني ان قواته دمرت عددا من العربات
القتاليه التابعه للدعم السريع واستلمت
خمسه عربات تم تركها في ميدان المعركه
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحافه عمار ابو
شيبه عمار سابدا بنقل الصوره من هناك كيف
هي حده الاشتباكات واين يعني تتركز بهذه
الاثناء
نعم ربما كانت هذه الاشتباكات وهذا القتال
قبل لحظات
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بعمار
ايضا من الخرطوم ينضم الي اللواء بكر
ابراهيم احمد خبير عسكري ولواء سابق في
القوات الجويه استاذ بابكر سابدا من
الاشتباكات التي عادت للنقطه الصفر وكاننا
بدانا من جديد منذ يوم اندلاع الاشتباكات
بين الطرفين هل هي محاوله لتغيير موازين
القوى على الارض قبل الذهاب الى طاوله
مفاوضات اذا كان هناك نيه للذهاب الى
طاوله مفاوضات
مشاهدينا
واليوم الاشتباكات داخل منطقه الخرطوم
طبعا بالامس كان اشتباكات جويه في منطقه
شرق النيل توجد بعض القوات من شرق النيل
دخلت الى منطقه الخرطوم وهذه المنطقه
النهائيه منطقه المركز مركز الخرطوم
الطيران
متعامل مع القوات الارضيه الدعم السريع
منذ صباح اليوم
والقوات الدعم السريه في حاله خروف وتقاه
قررت الى الخلف الى ان وصلت مركز الخرطوم
والخسائر
توجد بعض الخسائر العربات التي دمرت
والجيش يقول انه استلم خمسه عربات تركت في
مواضعها هذا هو الجديد في
زا الحرب الجويه انتقلت من النيل منطقه
بحري الى
منتصف الخرطوم وهذه المنطقه النهائيه
وبالتالي هل نحن نتحدث عن حصر الصراع
بمنطقه جغرافيه اضيق من ما بدا هذا الصراع
نه
تماما ونازل الجيش منطقه بحري تم تنشيطه
بالطيران
وبدا جيش منزل ومنطقه الخرطوم الان بدا
التنشيط
بالطيران
متبقي ان يكمل الجيش حصار منطقه بحري ثم
ينزل منطقه الخرطوم وتكون من المعركه
النهائيه ولكن يعني ما يقوله الدعم السريع
ومختلف تماما وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
معلومات متضاربه بين الطرفين
انا انا الان داخل منطقه الحتكون داخل
المنطقه التي يتواجد فيها الدعم السريع
وما نقلته لك اقوله من
بالنظر يعني ليس من نقل ولا
بالوكاله
يوجد كانت هنالك
سيارات دفع رباعي انتقلت من منطقه التحرير
بعد الضرب امس الى منطقه الخرطوم واصبحت
هنالك كثافه بالنسبه للعربات الدفاع
الرباعي الدعوه السريع الان من الصباح
الحكوميه تتعامل معها
وفرت هذه العربات الى منطقه السوق المركزي
اللي هو
منتصف الدائره في الخرطوم ولكن يعني حسب
ما نذكر من اول ما بدا هذا الصراع دائما
هناك اعاده تمركز لقوات الدعم السريع بين
شارع واخر بين منطقه واخرى ما يحصل اليوم
هل هو انسحاب كامل ام ممكن ان يكون اعاده
تموضع ويعود الى النقاط التي كانت يعني
المعارك دائره فيها
معارك كانت هجوميه من الدعم السريع لبراكز
الاستراتيجيه للقوات المسلحه اللي هي
القياده العامه والمطار الخرطوم منذ اكثر
من عشره ايام فقدت هذه القوات المقدره على
الهدوء
والهجوم ويتمركز
بالحرب الجويه الان هنالك تراجع بين
القوات الدعم السريعه لمنطقه المنتصف لكن
هي واضحه وليس لديها المقبره للهجوم ولكن
لا توجد قوات راجله من القوات الحكوميه
هذه المرحله لم لم تبدا
القوات المسلحه تنتظر
القوات
الدعم السريعه على الارض بعد ذلك تبدا
الحرب البريه حسب حسب البيانات الصادره من
القوات المسلحه منطقه
مرحله التنشيط
ونزول القوات البريه لفصل منتصف
الخرطوم
قدرت قبل يومين بين سبعه ايام و14 يوم
شكرا لك اللواء بابا بكر ابراهيم احمد
خبير عسكري والياء سابق في القوات الجويه
حدثنا من الخرطوم اذا كانت هذه اخر
التحديثات من هناك قالت الامم المتحده
مشاهدينا انها تحتاج الى 445 مليون دولار
لمساعده 860 الف شخص قد يفرون حتى اكتوبر
القادم من القتال الدامي في السودان بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وقالت مفوضيات
الامم المتحده الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين انه
من المتوقع ان تستقبل مصر ومصر وجنوب
السودان الحصه الاكبر من تدفقات اللاجئين
بسبب الحرب في السودان هذا واضافت ان هذا
النداء موجه الى الدول المالحه
ننتقل الان الى ميناء جدا لمتابعه اخر
تطورات عمليات الاجلاء وينضم الينا من
صاله ركاب ميناء جده نصفيان مراسل العربيه
هاني الصوره معك تفضل
نعم اهلا بك ليال واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه مره اخرى اذا من رصيف الذي وقفت
فيه سفينه السفينه الامريكيه العسكريه على
متنها 22
راكب ممن تم اجلاؤهم من بورسودان الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي وانتقلنا الان الى
داخل صاله الركاب وهي المرحله تعتبر
الثانيه او الثالثه لانهاء اجراءات هؤلاء
الركاب وكذلك منحهم تاشيرات طارئه من اجل
دخولهم الى الاراضي السعوديه وكذلك بعد
ذلك يتم مغادرهم وايضا اعطائهم بعض او
اعطائهم اثباتات التي تم فقد فقدها من
بعضهم خلال عمليه الاجلاء عموما صلت
الركاب هنا في ميناء جده الاسلامي والتي
يتم انهاء فيها الاجراءات من قبل الجوازات
السعوديه هناك عشرات المنصات التي يتم
فيها اجراءات هؤلاء الركاب والرعايه من
جنسيات مختلفه سواء من قبل
عبر التقنيات الحديثه الموفره من الجوازات
السعوديه او كذلك من خلال ايضا اخذ
العلامات الحيويه لدينا عشر جنسيات على
هذه السفينه لدينا الجنسيه الامريكيه
وكذلك السويديه وايضا السويسريه وايضا
الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه ولعله ممن
يحملون الجنسيه السودانيه هم الاكثر بعدد
وصل الى 136 شخص يليهم ايضا الجنسيه
الامريكيه بثلاثه وستين
63 شخصا نعم وايضا هناك عدد من الاطفال
وهم كثر علامه هذه السفينه 30 ثانيه هي
المده التي يمضي فيها الشخص لانهاء
اجراءاته وكذلك في هذه اللحظات الان يتم
عمل البصمه واخذ العلامات الحيويه
سيده من رعايه الجنسيات التي احدى
الجنسيات التي قدمت علامات هذه السفينه
بعد ان قام موظف الجوازات بمنحها تاشيره
طارئه وكذلك ايضا منحها الكترونيا وهي
تاشيره يتم اعطاء فيها هذه التاشيره حتى
تتمكن هذه السيده من الدخول الى داخل
الاراضي السعوديه وبعد ذلك الى المكان
المعد لها في مكان فندقي موفر من قبل
الخارجيه السعوديه وبعد ذلك مغادرتها من
سفرتها وبعد التنسيق مع سفرتها بينها وبين
سفراتها ايضا هناك الخارجيه السعوديه التي
تواصلت قبل وصولها الى هنا طبعا في هذه
اللحظات تظهر العلامات الحيويه لهذه
السيده وكذلك التاكد من بصمتها وكذلك تظهر
المعلومات الخاصه باسم وهويه هذه السيده
وينطبق الحال على جميع هؤلاء الرايه الذين
نشاهدهم عبر هذه المنصات الموجوده طبعا
حتى حتى هذه اللحظه في هذه الصاله صاله
الركاب في ميناء جده الاسلامي تم انهاء
اجراءات اكثر من سبعه الاف شخص منذ بدء
عمليات الاجلاء في الرابع والعشرين من شهر
ابريل الماضي حتى هذه اللحظه وقد يزداد
هذا العدد مع زياده هذه الاعداد وكذلك
عمليات الاجلاء المتواصله سواء عبر قائده
الملك فيصل البحريه والتي تتم عبر القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه او سفن جلاله
الملك سواء ابها او الرياض او مكه او
الجبيل او الدرعيه وهي سفن جلاله الملك
التابعه للقوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
وايضا هناك عبر القاعده الجويه وهي قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه والتي تقود مهامها
القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه او ايضا
عبر ميناء جدا الاسلامي والتي تصل اليه
باستمرار سوى اليومين الماضيين سواء من
السفن الفرقاطات العسكريه الاجنبيه او
كذلك التجاريه عموما هناك خدمات لوجستيه
هي تقدم من قبل الخارجيه السعوديه وهناك
ايضا 30 جهه لو نشاهد في هذه الجهه يتم
دخول الرايه اولا من البوابه الخاصه
بالصاله وبعد ذلك يقومون
يقوم فريق طبي بفحصهم وتاكد من سلامتهم
وبعد ذلك يمرون مرورا الى قنصلياتهم
المتواجده ولدينا هنا عشر قنصليات وكذلك
بعد ذلك يتوجهون الى هذا المسار ليتم
انهاء اجراءاتهم وبعد ذلك المغادره مباشره
الى الخروج
وتستقبلهم حافلات التي سوف تنقلهم الى مقر
اقامتهم داخل مدينه جده وهي عباره عن عشر
فنادق الخارجيه السعوديه من عمليات
الاجلاء قامت بتوفير الاسكان تجاوز
الاربعه الاف غرفه او 4000 لاربعه الاف
شخص الباقي الاعداد تم مغادرتهم مباشره
عند وصولهم بعد التنسيق مع بعثتهم
الدبلوماسيه والمعتمده لدى السعوديه
هذه يعني من خارج هذه الصوره ما هي
الاعداد المتوقعه وصول بالساعات المقبله
وهل من تفاصيل اخرى ممكن الحديث عنها لو
سمحت
سفينتان خلال هذا المساء سوف تصلاني
السعوديه السفينه الاولى وهي امانه والتي
كانت لها رحلتين او رحلتين سابقتان في
الاسابيع او الاسبوع الماضي وايضا يتوقع
ان تصل امامنا في تمام الساعه السابعه
مساء بالتوقيت المحلي السعودي على متنها
قرابه اعداء او اعداد تتجاوز الالف
شخص وكذلك ايضا هناك السفينه عسكريه تابعه
للقوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه سوف تصل
ولكن لم تصلنا العدد تحديدا عموما خلال
الساعات المقبله او خلال الساعات المساء
سوف يتم
الوصول النهائي والوجهه النهائيه لهاتين
السفينتين والتي سوف تصلان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه في مدينه جده وكذلك
سوف يتم ترتيب جدولهم وكذلك مراحلهم
وانهاء اجراء بنفس الخطوات المتبعه سواء
لهؤلاء الرعايه او كذلك الرعايه الذين
سبقوهم ووصلوا السعوديه وغادروا جزء كبير
منهم الى خارج السعوديه وتحديدا الى
بلدانهم شكرا لك هاني على كل حال سنبقى
نتابع معك طبعا بالساعات المقبله عمليه
وصول ونقل الرعايه الاجانب يعني انطلاقا
من عمليات الاجلاء التي بدات منذ حوالي
الاسبوع او اكثر حتى من الخرطوم بعد
انطلاع اندلاع الاشتباكات طبعا هي تصل الى
بورتسودان ومن ميناء بورتسودان الى جده
شكرا لك هاني
في هذا السياق وصلت نيجيريا اجلاء المئات
من رعاياها الفريق من القتال في السودان
واعادتهم الى بلادهم بعد ايام من التاخير
الذي ترك العديد منهم عالقين هذا وكانت
مفوضيه النيجيريين في الشتات قد اوضحت في
وقت سابق ان حوالي 2000 جنيه تقطعت بهم
السبل منذ بدء الاشتباكات في السودان
امك منذ اليوم الاول طرحنا مبادره بتشكيل
لجنه مشتركه من الطرفين النزاع
وطرف ثالث من الشخصيات القوميه للبحث في
وقف القتال وكيفيه
اليات تنفيذ هذا الوقف نحن الان في عجلون
نعمل على ذلك كل القوه السياسيه والمدنيه
الان نعمل على توحيده في موقف واحد محدد
في وقت هذا الصباع والان يعني اطروحات
كثيره مبادرات ان شاء الله انها تتجمع
بسرعه اللازمه
وفي اللقاء مع العربيه عربه سفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي في القاهره عن قلقه من الحرف
السودان قائلا ان هذا دائما ما يعطي
الفرصه للمتطرفين فكريا ومضيفا انه يرى
تعامل مصر بحرص على حدودها حتى لا يكون
هناك انتقال للارهابيين اليها
نحن قلقون عندما تدور اشتباكات مثل هذه
وتتحول الى حرب لان هذا يعطي المساحه
دائما لذوي الافكار المتطرفه والارهابيه
اننا نرى ما تفعله مصر الان وهي تتعامل
بحرص على الحدود لتتاكد من عدم تسرب
ارهابيين من خلال حدودها مع السودان
واعتقد اننا سنناقش هذا على المستوى
الثنائي مع نظرائنا المصريين لنرى امكانيه
التعاون في هذا الموضوع
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاثيوبيه بانه
تم تسهيل عبور ما لا يقل عن 4000 شخص من
جنسيات مختلفه عبر المنافذ الحدوديه مع
السودان بالاضافه لاستقبال اكثر من الف
لاجئ سوداني في اشاره الى الدور الاثيوبي
للتخفيف من وطاه طوال معاناه الانسانيه
طبعا في السودان
حتى الان تم تسهيل عبور اكثر من 4000 شخص
من 61 دوله عبر المنافذ الحدوديه مع
السودان وتم السماح ل 75 رحله جويه لعبور
الاجواء الاثيوبيه لاجلاء رعاياها من
السودان انطلاقا من مسؤولياتنا ما يحدث في
السودان سيكون له تاثير سلبي على اثيوبيا
حذر والي ولايه شمال دارفور من وقوع كارثه
انسانيه بمخيمات النازحين بعدما قامت
المنظمات الامميه العامله في المجال
الانساني باجلاء موظفيها بسبب تدهور الوضع
الامني وقال ان الوضع الانساني بالولايه
ينذر بكارثه حقيقيه قبل ان يعرب عن قلقيه
وقلق حكومته تجاه التطورات الحاصله وعلى
الصعيد الامني اكدوالي ولايه شمال دارفورد
بان هدف الولايه الاستراتيجي هو المحافظه
على وقف اطلاق النار الذي توصل اليه
الطرفان بوساطه لجنه الحكماء مؤخرا
هذا ويعيش العاملون في محطات توليد
الكهرباء في جنوب دارفور بمدينه نيالا
اوضاعا صعبه مع استمرار المواجهات احنا
الزياره دي تمت يعني بناء المبادره
واخواننا في الكهرباء واخواننا الاتراك
واخواننا السائق اللواري اللي بيحملوا
حقيقه الوقود من بورسودان لنيال يعني
هلقيت جينا فقدنا اهوالهم وشفناهم والان
احنا في مسقعه انه كيف يفتح الطريق عشان
كل الناس
الكميه من الشكاوي يعني يتعرضوا يمكن
الحاجات مثل هذا المشاكل اكيد يعني كل زول
نصيبه من الشيل حصل له يعني ولذلك يحتسبوه
لله لكن خلاص الناس قادرين انه يقفوا
معاهم لحد ما يرجى باذن الله سبحانه
وتعالى فاننا امرنا في الله كبير ونعمل في
علم السودان كلها يعني باذن الله سبحانه
حتى الناس كلهم توقف صوت الصلاه وتحتك
لسلطه الاكل ده من السودان محتاج الان
للحزه السودان محتاج يعني تعرضنا لحاله
والله بجد صعبه صعبه بكل صعوبه يعني سته
ايام مرت علينا قبل كده ما حصلت علينا سته
ايام نهب ودق وسلب وبفضل الاله وبحمد الله
ومن بعده لاخواننا في الدعم السريع والله
هم يعني انقذونا ادعمونا ماديين ومع نبيا
اعود الى الخرطوم والصحافه عمار ابو شيبه
عمار كنت اسال عن الاشتباكات يعني الخبير
العسكري الذي كان معنا يقول بانها منحصره
الان بمنطقه محدده وان تم تنشيط معظم معظم
المناطق كيف هي الخارطه من على الارض لو
سمحت
عمار على ما يبدو انه ايضا انقطع الخط
والاتصال معهم ساعود اليه فور جهوز هذا
الاتصال مجددا لنقل صوره الاشتباكات
ومن السودان الى التطورات في روسيا حيث
وصفت الولايات المتحده الاتهامات الروسيه
لها بالوقوف وراء هجوم الكريم بالكاذبه
وذلك بعد مقاله موسكو ان قرارات القيام
بمثل هذه الاعمال تتخذ تتخذ في واشنطن في
وقت دعا الاتحاد الاوروبي الى عدم اتخاذ
الحادث ذريعه لتصعيد الحرب من جانب روسيا
كره ثلج الازمه الاوكرانيه تكبر يوما بعد
يوم حادث المسيرتين فوق قصر الكرملين صب
الزيت اكثر فوق نيران الحرب المشتعله اصلا
موسكو وبعد اتهامها بمحاوله اغتيال بوتين
صعدت اللهجه اكثر الخارجيه الروسيه توعدت
برد يكون بحجم التهديد سهام الانتقاد
الروسيه اتجهت مباشره نحو الولايات
المتحده فقرارات القيام بمثل هذه الاعمال
تتخذ في واشنطن وليس كيا التي تنفذ يقول
الكرملين
مثل هذه القرارات وتعريف الاهداف وتعريف
الوسائل كل هذا تمليه واشنطن على
اوكرانيا نفت الاتهامات الروسيه جمله
وتفصيلا ووصفتها بالكاذبه فرسيا اختلقت
الهجوم لكونها تعلم انها خسرت الحرب
والكريم لان يستغل هذه الروايه لتحفيز
جنوده على الاستمرار في الحرب ومقدمه لعمل
عسكري شامل
اما زيلينس كيف حاول القيام بهجمه مرتده
من داخل مقر محكمه الجنايه الدوليه عبر
المطالبه بمحاكمه الرئيس الروسي
تجب معاقبه بوتين على افعاله هنا في عاصمه
القانون الدولي حليف اوكرانيا الاتحاد
الاوروبي دعا الى عدم استخدامه هجوم
الكريم ذريعه لتصعيد الحرب ويكو ندع روسيا
الى عدم استخدام هذا الهجوم المزعوم ذريعه
لمواصله هذا التصعيد للحرب اكبر داعم لكي
اف سياسيا وعسكريا الولايات المتحده ابدت
تشكيكها فيما يقع البيت الابيض قال انه
ينظر بعين الريبه لكل ما يصدر عن موسكو في
وقت اشارت الامم المتحده الا انه لا يمكن
تاكيد المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني
على الكرملين بلال البجدين العربيه
شدد المتحدث باسم الامن القوميه بالبيت
الابيض على ان بلاده لا تشجع او تمكن
اوكرانيا من ضرب اهداف خارج الحدود
الاوكرانيه وفق وسائل الاعلام محليه واكد
كيربي بان مزاعم روسيا بان الولايات
المتحده تقف وراء الهجوم على الكرملين
كاذبه على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
في حين لم ترجح المسيرات كفت روسيا في
الحرب الا انها اسهمت في تماسك الجيش
الاوكراني وبعثرت تحصينات ثاني اقوى جيش
في العالم فهم عظمه الجيش الروسي تلاشت في
ساحه المعركه او على الاقل شوهت سمعتها
فلنتابع
نجمه الصمود الاوكراني كما وصفت دعمت عمود
المساعدات الغربيه العسكري وصنعت الفارقه
في الحرب لا سيما ان استخدامها جاء من
الطرفين لتحديد مواقع العدو وتوجيه نيران
المدفعيه نحوها
واستخدمت بالهجوم الذي اغرق سفينه موسكفا
الروسيه في ابريل 2022 لكن هذه المسيرات
يعيبها حجمها الكبير وبطء حركتها وسهوله
اسقاطها مقارنه بكمكاز الانتحاريه
فالعصافير القاتله او الذخيره المتسكعه
تتميز بقدرتها على التحليق في منطقه الهدف
المحدد مسبقا وتضرب عند التعرف الى العدو
تطلق من مسافات بعيده ويصعب اكتشافها لصغر
حجمها اهميه هذا السلاح ادركته موسكو
سريعا فاندفعت الى ايران لشراء مسيرات
انتحاريه عمياء بدقه ضعيفه استخدمتها لاول
مره في خركيف ثم كييف واداس وميكولياف غير
ان هذه المسيرات لم ترقى لتوقعات الروس
واخفقت كثيرا وفق واشنطن
الرجل الامريكي جاء بعدما اتهمت موسكو
الولايات المتحده بشكل مباشر بالضلوع في
الهجوم على الكريمينا حيث قالت ان قرار
الهجوم اتخذ في واشنطن وليس فقال الناطق
الرسمي باسم الكريم
لهذه النوعيه من الضربات يكون باملاء من
واشنطن
بان بلاده تعتقد ان اكياف متورطه في
الهجوم بناء على بيانات من الاستخبارات
الروسيه الكراميل قال ايضا انه يدرس
مجموعه متنوعه من الخيارات للرد على
الهجوم الاخير
ردا على سؤال حول انكار اوكرانيا
والولايات المتحده تورط في هجمات الطائرات
بدون طيار
محاولتكييف وواشنطن مثيره للضحك تماما
ندرك ان القرار بشان مثل هذه الاعمال
والهجمات لم يتم اتخاذه في كييف بل في
واشنطن وبعد ذلك تفعل اوكرانيا ما يطلب
منها ليست كيف من تقوم بتحديد الاهداف
واختيار الوسائل بل واشنطن كيف تقوم
بتنفيذها فقط ونحن ندرك ذلك
[موسيقى]
وفي ردود الافعال الدوليه المستمره اعتبرت
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه بان الهجوم على
الكريملم باستخدام المسيرات حادث غريب
وغامض ولا يزال بحاجه الى تفسير حيث قالت
بانه ليس لديها اي معلومات محدده حول هذا
الموضوع ولا يمكنها مناقشه الروايات
المتعلقه به
بدورها اعتبرت الخارجيه الايطاليه ان اي
عمل عسكري بما فيه محاولات استهداف مبنى
الكريم امر لا يخدم التسويه السلميه في
اوكرانيا وقالت الخارجيه الايطاليه ان
جميع الهجمات التي تسببت بالضرر على مبنى
لا تعرف تفاصيلها لحد اللحظه وانها لا
تخدم السلام الذي يجب ان يكون في مصلحه
اوكرانيا والذي سينتج عنه استقلال
اوكرانيا على حد قولها
[موسيقى]
من كاف مشاهدينا ينضم الينا حذيفه عادل
لمراسل العربيه حذيفه كيف هي الصوره من
هناك رد يعني الرسم بالساعات الماضيه على
كل التصريحات الروسيه وهذا يعني الجدل
الامريكي الروسي حول موضوع استهداف
الكرمله
مساء الخير ليال طبعا يعني لا يوجد اي
ردود افعال في ساعات الاخيره من قبل كيف
حول التصريحات من قبل الاتحاد الروسي او
غيرها حتى من التصريحات من الشركاء
الغربيين حول هذه الحادثه كيف طبعا قالت
ان ردها كان واضحا حول ذلك ان كيف غير
متورطه في هذا العمل وان هذه مسرحيه تقوم
يقوم بها الاتحاد الروسي ليبدي او يظهر ان
هنالك تصعيد من قبل الاتحاد من قبل وهذا
التصعيد طبعا يتطلب رد وهم يحضرون لشيء ما
سوف يكون في الايام القادمه خاصه يتوقعون
في التاسع من مايو وان يكون هنالك هجوم
نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه عمليه الاستهداف
التي تمت ايضا في الليله الماضيه او حتى
صباح اليوم ايضا اعتبرها المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون كرد فعل من قبل موسكو في
بخصوص هذه الحادثه التي حدثت في الكرملين
طبعا كان هنالك قصف
صاروخين
وكذلك كان هناك استهداف واسع بالطائرات
المسيره من قناه شاهد 136 و131 استهدفت
العاصمه
عدد خمسه عشر طائره مسيره اسقطت جميعها
كذلك تم استهداف اوديسا بخمسه عشر طائره
اسقط منها اثنتين عشره طائره وهنالك 24
طائره استهدفت ساحل بحر قزوين وايضا بعض
المناطق في الشرق الاوكراني اسقط ايضا
منها ثمانيه عشره طائره كان هنالك تسجيل
ل68
هجوما براجمات الصواريخ وسبعه وستين هجوم
يعني غاره جويه نفذت وكذلك صدت القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه اربعين هجوما في مناطق
متفرقه طبعا خرسون تشهد ايضا تصعيد من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي قصف متواصل وتطلب ذلك
اجراءات جديده من قبل اداره هذه المقاطعه
هنالك حظر للتجوال يبدا في الخامس من هذا
الشهر وينتهي في لمده ثلاثه ايام طبعا
اعطيت مهله للمواطنين ليقوموا بقضاء
حوائجهم سواء كان الغذاء والدواء وما الى
ذلك وبعد ذلك تدخل المدينه والمقاطعه بشكل
عام في هذا الحظر وطبعا العمده تحدث عن ان
هذا الحظر لتقوم قوات انفاذ القانون
باعمالها دون ان تكون هنالك اي اضرار
جانبيه وسط المدنيين طبعا ايضا تعلمين ان
اليوم الرئيس زيلينسكي كان يعني ما زال في
هذه الزياره الى هولندا وايضا الى لاهاي
وكان له خطاب عنونه بلا سلام دون العداله
لاوكرانيا ركز فيه طبعا على الجرائم التي
ارتكبها جيش الاتحاد الروسي داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وبشكل عام كما قال الاتحاد
الروسي ارتكبها نحو اوكرانيا ابتداء من
الغزو كما سماه للاراضي الاوكرانيه ثم كل
الجرائم التي سجلت بشكل رسمي وعددها بما
يفوق سته الاف او ما يقرب من السبعه الاف
جريمه ايضا طبعا الجرائم التي
ارتكبت ضد الاطفال في اوكرانيا وكذلك طبعا
تحدث عن حوادث بعينها طبعا الهجوم الاخيره
الذي حدث في خرسون اتحدث ايضا عنه وكذلك
في ذلك الهجوم الذي وقع على احد المباني
السكنيه ونتج عن ذلك عدد كبير من الضحايا
كل هذه اعتبرها جرائم للاتحاد الروسي وقال
انه يجب ان يحاكم فلاديمير اخر يعني يجب
ان يكون هنا في لاهايف اخر وهنا يعني طبعا
الرئيس الروسي بوتين بشكل عام طبعا
المواطنين ايضا هنا تعاملوا مع هذه
الهجمات في الكريملين بشيء من الخوف
والحذر ولكنهم ايضا يقولون انهم ما زال من
المبكر ان يتخذوا خطوات بشان ذلك يعني
مغادره مثلا للعاصمه كييف او اللجوء الى
مناطق اخرى هم سينتظرونا ويرراقبون اذا
حدث تصعيد كبير وواسع النطاق سوف يقومون
بمغادره هذه المدينه ولكن بشكل عام هم
يتوقعون انهم قد اذا حتى اذا حدث اي
استهداف للعاصمه كيف انهم سيلجاون الى
الملاجئ الحياه تصير بشكل طبيعي وهادئه
حذيفه قبل ان نختم الحياه داخل العاصمه
الان يعني كما نشاهد وراءك كانها طبيعيه
هل يعني هناك حاله من الخوف من الترقب هل
فعلا الناس تنزل الى الملاجئ ام انهم
كالعاده يعني انا كما شاهدت عندما كنت
هناك لا ينزلون اصلا الى الملاجئ
ويستمر الحال كما هو ليال كما شاهدتي
المواطنين يعني اصبحوا غير لا يابهون
بالصافرات الانذار لا يذهبون الى الملاجئ
تجدونهم يسيرون في الطرقات في وقت الانذار
او حاله الانذار الجوي هذا ما حدث ايضا في
هذه في الليله الماضيه وبالامس عندما كان
هنالك دوره صافرات الانذار في العاصمه كيف
المواطنين بشكل هادئ جدا تعاملوا مع الامر
طبعا توقفت محطات القطار توقفت محطات
المترو توقفت
الترامفاي توقف المواصلات العامه توقفت في
وقت الغاره الجويه ولكن بعد ذلك استانفت
وعوده العمل كذلك المراكز التجاريه طبعا
يتم اخلائها في فتره الغاره الجويه يعني
الاعلان عن الانذار حاله الانذار الجوي
ولكن بشكل عام الحياه صارت بشكل طبيعي
يعني كالمعتاد شكرا لك حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه حدثنا منك
[موسيقى]
معنا من موسكو مشاهدينا الباحثه في
العلاقات الدوليه في مدرسه الاقتصاد
العليا لانا بيدفان استاذه لانا ما حصل
داخل الكرملين يعني بكل التاريخ الامريكي
دائما من يتبعون ما يسمى بالاحراج الداخلي
احراج بوتين داخليا عبر استهداف الكرملين
بحد ذاته كيف سيؤثر على تماسك هذه الجبهه
الداخليه بالفتره المقبله
في الحقيقه يعني ما حدث البارحه لم يحرج
القياده الروسيه انما سبب تخبط كبير لدى
الداخل الروسي بان الامن القومي الروسي
الان بات في خطر حقيقي وبان ما كانت تقوله
الكريم من تصريحات عديده في السنه الماضيه
بعدت نراها هي تصريحات حقيقيه هناك حرب
على روسيا من كافه الجهات هناك فعليا
محاوله غربيه امريكيه لباس الفوضى في
الداخل الروسي بالتالي ما حدث البارحه لا
يعني ان هناك توتر لدى الشعب الروسي وان
هناك فعليا انخفاض في الامل والامل تجاه
الحكومه انما على العكس هناك
نوعا ما من الغضب الساخط تجاه السياسات
الغربيه وخاصه ان ماريا زغروفه
قد صرحوا بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هي التي اعطت الضوء الاخضر للجهه
الاوكرانيه لقيام بهذه العمليه بالتالي
نحن في خسوف كبير بين الروسيه والعلاقات
الامريكيه وخاصه بين الشعب الروسي اليوم
الذي بات يخشى ان يكون هناك في مرحله
تصعيديه جديده وخاصه ان سابقا كان هناك
دائما حرب بارده بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فهم اعتادون على هذه
الحاله ولكن كانوا يعملون ان لا تتكرر هذه
التجربه مجددا ولكن هناك يقين داخل الروسي
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي التي
تجر الداخل الروسي والحكومه الروسيه
نعم من هذا المنطلق ومن هذا المبدا
الاتحاد السوفيتي لم يسقط الا من الداخل
واليوم هناك قناعه ان كان لدى الاوكران او
ان كان لدى الامريكيين بان موسكو وروسيا
وكل يعني قوتها لن تسقط الا من الداخل ليس
عبر الحرب الخارجيه والاستنزاف لان اثبتت
انها قادره على البقاء والاستمرار
وبالتالي ما حصل هل ينظر بتصعيد داخلي
اكبر لاحداث فوضى اكبر في الداخل
بالتاكيد لما حدث فعليا البارحه والاحداث
الماضيه لا تنظر اي انذار به ان يكون هناك
فوضى داخليه الشعب اليوم يعي تماما ما
يريده الغرب وما تريده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وخاصه في روسيا يعني الشعب لا
يريد احداث اي فوضى لان اي فوضى سيكون
هناك نتائج كارثيه وسلبيه على البلاد وعلى
الاقتصاد البلاد وعلى على المجتمع الروسي
ككل فهم عاشوا ايضا في ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي عندما انهار وعندما كان هناك
الاحداث الامنيه السيئه وكان هناك عديد من
الجرائم تحصل في كل دقيقه حتى بالتالي لا
يريدون تكرار هذا السيناريو ثانيا ولكن
نقل نقل الحرب يعني والتفجيرات الى الداخل
اذا ما زادت وتيرتها الا تضر اليوم بصوره
موسكو يعني القبضه الحديديه التي لطالما
يعني تباهت بها بالداخل وفي الخارج
نعم دائما هناك احاديث روسيه عن القوه
الجيش القوه الاستخبارات الامنيه ودائما
هناك تصريحات على القبض على الجواسيس ولكن
لا يمكن ان ننسى فكره وان الحرب بقياده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ونحن جميعا
نعلم قدره استخبارات ايضا لدى واشنطن
وقدراتها العسكريه وهم عالميه يتحدثون عن
دعم العسكري المباشر لاوكرانيا سواء
طائرات مسيره او بالصواريخ التي وصلت الى
الحدود بين روسيا واوكرانيا وبالتالي هناك
وعي شعبي داخلي بان هذه الحرب ليست حرب
الروسيه اوكرانيا انما حرب ضد روسيا من
قبل اقوى دوله في العالم وهي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالتالي لا يمكن ان
يستهين بالمقابل في القوه الاستخباراتيه
وبالقوه العسكريه لدى واشنطن وبالتاكيد
لدى روسيا قوه امنيه وكل يوم هناك اخبار
واعترافات على القاء القبض على الجواسيس
سواء في الجواسيس الذين كانوا لهم ضلوع في
تفجير جسر القرن لربما نسمع مع الايام
القادمه القائد القبض على الجواسيس الذين
يعملون مع الجهات الاوكرانيه فيما يتعلق
بالطائرات مسيره دون طيار هذا يعني هناك
تقارير هناك تقارير تتحدث عن ان هذه
المسيرات ممكن ان تكون اطلقت من الداخل
الروسي وليس من الخارج عملا بما تقولين او
تدلينا به اليوم يعني كل هذه الصوره
الاختراقات الامنيه اذا ما زادت يعني مزيد
من الفوضى في الداخل يعني تشتيت على
التركيز على الجبهه في الخارج كيف تتحضر
موسكو لهذا السيناريو
بالتاكيد هي تتحضر وقد حضرت سابقا يعني
عندما نشاهد تصريحات للساسه في الرئاسه
الروسيه دائما ما يتحدثون وحتى السياسيين
والخبراء عن امكانيه ان يكون هناك هجمات
داخل روسيا وايضا كان هناك حتى تحليلات
وتوقعات في حال اقدمت مثلا وبريطانيا على
ضرب روسيا ما سيكون هناك الرد الروسي وما
الصواريخ التي تستخدمها روسيا سابقا كان
الجميع يضحك على هذه السنيوريرات ولكن
كلما مضى ايام نعيش فعليا هذا الكلام
السياسي الذي يتحدثون به الخبراء حول
ادخال الحرب الى الداخل الروسي وارسال
طائرات مسيره دون طيار يعني هناك توقعات
سابقه كان يطرحها السياسيين الروس واحدها
هي ان يكون هناك هجمات في الداخل الروسي
لتجديد الوضع واحداث الفوضى لدى الداخل
الشعبي لان هناك استحاله لانهاء على
الجبهه في الخارج شكرا لك الباحثه في
العلاقات الدوليه في مدرسه الاقتصاد
العليا لانا بيدفان على هذه المداخله
دعا الرئيس الاوكراني الفولاذ الى انشاء
محكمه خاصه لمحاكمه روسيا على غزوها بلاده
مطالبا بتحقيق عداله واسعه النطاق عبر
القانون رافضا فكره الافلات الهجين من
العقاب زينسكي اكاد ايضا ان روسيا يجب ان
تتحمل المسؤوليه كامله في حربها في
اوكرانيا
الرئيس الاوكراني طالب بتشكيل محكمه خاصه
لمحاكمه روسيا على عملياتها العسكريه في
بلاده وقال في كلمه له بالمحكمه الجنائيه
دوليه في لاهاي ان روسيا ارتكبت ما يزيد
عن سته الاف جريمه جريمه حرب طبعا خلال
الشهر الماضي فقط واضاف ان محاكمه قيادات
روسيا امر ضروري لترسيخ قيم الحريه
بالطبع نحن نريد جميعا ان نرى فلاديمير
بوتين هنا في لاهاي الشخص الذي يستحق
الحكم على اعماله الاجراميه هنا في عاصمه
القانون الدولي انا متاكد من اننا سنرى
ذلك يحدث عندما ننتصر وسوف ننتصر اوكرانيا
معرضه للخطر ونريد اجراءات حقيقيه لملاحقه
القياده الروسيه كما علينا العمل لتحقيق
العداله ومحاكمه بوتين من اجل قيم الحريه
قالت الصين ان هناك حاجه الى اليقظه شديده
لمواجهه التوسع الناتو شرقا في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ وجاء هذا بعد ورود تقارير
تفيد بان حلف شمال الاطلسي يخطط لانشاء
مكتب في اليابان لتسهيل المشاورات مع
الحلفاء والشركاء الامنيين في المنطقه
يعني
اسيا هي مقر السلام والاستقرار وارض واحده
للتعاون والتنميه ولا ينبغي ان تصبح ساحه
معركه للمنافسه الجيو السياسيه توسع
الناتو المستمر شرقا في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ والتدخله في الشؤون
الاقليميه سيقضيان حتما على السلام
الاقليمي وسيشجعان الكتله على مواجهه
بعضها البعض ما يعني ان على دول المنطقه
ان تكون في حاله تاهب قصوى
في سياق اخر قال وزير الدفاع التايواني ان
اول طائره من اصل 66 طائره جديده من طراز
اف 16 الامريكيات صنع كان من المقرر
تسليمها لبلاده تاخرت بسبب تعطل سلسله
الثورات كان من المقرر تسليم طائرات اف 16
هذا العام لكن هذا لن يحدث بسبب تعطل
سلسله التوريد القوات المسلحه لبلدنا
لديها خطط احتياطيه لكل مشروع قيد التنفيذ
خصوصا وان العديد من عمليه الاستحواذ لا
تتم بالكامل
طلبت من الولايات المتحده تعويضا نقص بما
في ذلك اعطاء الاولويه لتسليم قطع الغيار
للاسطول الحالي حاليا نعمل على تقليل
الضرر الناجم عن ذلك
التصعيد بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
كشف تحقيق اولي للسلاح الجوي الاسرائيلي
بان منظومه القبه الحديديه اصابها خللا
فنيا في جوله التصعيد الاخيره على قطاع
غزه التحقيق اشار الى ان الخلل الفني حاله
دون اعتراض صواريخ اطلقت من غزه وسقطت في
قتل او قتل الجيش الاسرائيلي اربع
فلسطينيين صباح اليوم ثلاثه منهم في حي
الياسمنيه في البلده القديمه من مدينه
نابلس والرابعه داخل بلده حواره بحجه
بعضها جنديا اسرائيليا واصابته اصابه
طفيفه
في ذروه الحركه التجاريه وحركه الطلاب
دخلت قوه خاصه من الجيش الاسرائيلي حي
الياسمين في البلده القديمه من نابلس
وحاصرت منزلا تحصن فيه عدد من المسلحين
الفلسطينيين
اشتباكات عنيفه ووابل من الرصاص
والمتفجرات القاها الجيش الاسرائيلي
باتجاه المنزل ما اوقع ثلاثه قتلى قالت
اسرائيل انهم متورطون في عمليه اطلاق
النار في الاغوار
[موسيقى]
اطلاق نار كثيف رافق خروج الجنازات من
مستشفى رفيديا الحكومي وسط اجراءات عسكريه
وحصار مشدد على محيط مدينه نابلس تخوفا من
رد الفصائل على العمليات الاسرائيليه
اكثر من 200 جندي وضابط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي شاركوا في العمليه التي تقول
اسرائيل انها قتلت خلالها منفذي عمليه
اطلاق نار في الاغوار ادت الى مقتل ثلاث
مستوطنات بدايه الشهر الماضي من حي
الياسمين في البلده القديمه بنابلس خالد
القاسم العربيه
بينما اعلنت السلطات البريطانيه استعدادها
لحفل تتويج الملك تشارلز ستصبح قرينه
هوكاميلا ملكه خلال الحفل حيث تنتظرها
تحديات كبيره لتكسب عامه
[موسيقى]
هي حب حياتي تشارلز منذ شبابه وزوجته خلال
العقدين الماضيين بعد اعتلاء تشارلز العرش
اصبحت الملكه القرينه لكنها بعيون الناس
كانت دائما المراه الاخرى كما ظلت دائما
محل مقارنه بالاميره ديانا زواجها من ولي
العهد لم يكن ضمن خطتها المستقبليه ولا
ضمن توقعاتها حتى
فاجات تشارلز العالم بزواجه من كاملا عام
2005 وكان ثاني زواج لكليهما لم تحضر
الملكه اليزابيث حينها الزواج المدني
ولكنها باركت هذا الزواج لاحقا كما علمنا
في وقت لاحق من خلال تصريحات هاري اللاذعه
ضد العائله بانه وشقيقه ويليام توسل
تشارلز الا يتزوج كملا لكن ذلك لم يردعه
حينها
كما ولدت عام
1947 لعائله غنيه ووالدها ضابط متقاعد من
الجيش ارتبطت بضابط في سلاح الفرسان يدعى
اندرو باربري بولز في منتصف الستينات
لكنها تعرفت الى تشارلز مطلع السبعينات
ووقع في حبها منذ اللحظه الاولى بحسب احد
كتاب السيره الذاتيه لتشيلسي
ظل قريبا من كاميلا وزوجها السابق وكان
عرابا لطفلهما الاول تزوجت تشارلز ديانا
عام
1981 ولكن ظلت كاملا جزءا من حياته
وكلفتها علاقته السريه به صورتها امام
البريطانيين الذين لطالما نظروا اليها
كمخربه لزواج تشارلز بديانا
ورغم تاكيدات تشارلز ان علاقته بكامله لم
تشتانف الا بعد انهيار زواجه من ديانا الا
ان ديانا كانت تعتبر خلال ذلك
ففي مقابلتها الشهيره عام
1995 افصحت كنا ثلاثه في هذا الزواج
طلاق كامله كان عام
1995 في حين انتهى زواج تشيلسي وديانا
رسميا عام
1996 بعد وفاه ديانا عام
1997 انسحبت كاملا من المشهد لكن تشارلز
اصر على وجود كاملا في حياته ليتزوج بعدها
في احتفاليه مدنيه صغيره في ظل الجدل حول
لقبها كملك محتدما خلال حكم الملكه
اليزابيث التي منحت كاميلا لقب الملكه
القرينه قبل وفاتها بعده اشهر خلال
الاحتفال بيوبيلها البلاتيني
صوره كامله قرينه للملك لا زالت مهتزه
وشخصيتها مثاره جدلا وانقسامات في الشارع
البريطاني قصر باكينج حاول تحسين صوره
كامله امام عامه الناس وكملا بذل جهودا
حديثا للاعتراف بها في العائله لكن
بالنسبه للبريطانيين الزجاج المكسور لا
يعود كما كان ووفاه الاميره ديانا كسرت
قلوب البريطانيين الذي ينظر الكثير منهم
لكم على انها الملام في ماساه ديانا من
لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
اعلنت الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
تعليق جميع المساعدات الغذائيه لاقليم
تيجراي حتى اشعار اخر وذلك اثناء التحقيق
في سرقه امدادات انسانيه في المنطقه حيث
كشفت مديره الوكاله المسؤوله عن اداره
المساعدات الخارجيه على ان المساعدات
الغذائيه الموجهه الى سكان المدينه لم تصل
اليهم وتم بيعها في السوق المحليه وقالت
بان التوقف المؤقت في تقديم المساعدات كان
بالتنسيق مع سفاره الولايات المتحده في
اديس ابابا والشركاء المنفذين لحين معالجه
الوضع
احتفلت دول العالم باليوم العالمي للصحافه
تشهد الصحافه الافغانيه فتره تقلبات صعبه
حيث اغلقت العشرات من وسائل الاعلام
المرئيه والمسموعه والمطبوعه نتابع
التفاصيل مع مراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر
ميكابر
هنا تجمع عشرات صحفيين الافغان في مقر
جمعيه حمايه الصحفيين للاحتفال بيوم حريه
الصحافه العالمي وقد غلب على الحفل طابع
المطالب من السلطات في كابول لاتخاذ
التدابير فوريه لحمايه الصحافه
مثلا الحريه الصحفيه التي تمتعت بها
الصحفيات في السنوات الماضيه انتهت بل
وضعت السلطات تحديات وعراقيل امام عمل
المراه في الاعلام المرئي من بينها ارتداء
البرقع يحتفل الصحفيون الافغان بهذا اليوم
في وقت قد توقفت مئات المنافذ الاعلاميه
في البلاد جراء مشاكل اقتصاديه وذلك بعد
توقف الدعم الخارجي منها من بعد استاهلات
بعد التحولات الاخيره في البلد توقف ما
يقارب من 200 من المنافذ الاعلاميه فقد
توقف عن العمل 55 محطه تلفزيونيه ومئه
محطات للاذاعه 21 وكاله اعلاميه وخمسه
عشره صحيفه من جهته اعترف عبد المتين قانع
المتحدث باسم وزاره الثقافه والاعلام
الافغاني والذي اشترك مع الصحفيين في هذا
الحفل بان مشاكل مختلفه تواجه الصحافه لكن
الوزاره تسعى لحلها
لن اقول ان الصحافه لم تواجه مشاكل فقد
واجهت مشاكل امنيه وفنيه واقتصاديه لكن
مسؤولي الصحافه الحاضرين هنا يشهدون اننا
سعينا وسنسعى في المستقبل لاحتوائ تلك
المشاكل
يعترف الصحافيون الافغان بان حريه الصحافه
من المزايا الايجابيه في المجتمع ويناشدون
السلطات بتوفير البيئه المناسبه لهم
للقيام بمسؤوليتهم الصحفيه بكل الشفافيه
ونزاهه عبد نادر العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في التغطيه لاخر
التطورات في السودان وتتابعون مزيد من
التفاصيل في الساعه القادمه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات